hello everybody hope that you're good
because Bitcoin is not Bitcoin is in
trol at the moment and I'm making this
very quick video I'm only going to be
talking about Bitcoin just to give you a
market update because I do think that my
videos are are more important um when
there is a big volatile move I think
that's when I need to speak with you
guys with voice so I can explain myself
further instead of just you know using X
and posting with a limitation in
characters cuz it's not the same so um
it's going to be a quick video we're
going to talk about what happened in the
crypto Market in the last few days what
can happen in the next few weeks and
most
important what do I need to see in
Bitcoin next week in order to not call
for lower prices over the following
weeks so let's start from the beginning
what happened on Friday Friday is this
daily candle here red daily candle super
drop nothing it doesn't even stand out
compared to the rest of the of the
candles right so on
Friday if you don't have the knowledge
of what happened then you mean you would
then you would never guess something big
happened and it did by bat go hack by is
currently the top two biggest Exchange
in the crypto Market Toco hacked they
lost $1.5
billion uh from their reserves from
their from from their cold wallet and
the crypto Market didn't react neither
on Friday Saturday or Sunday for 3 days
no reaction the S&P dropped qu a lot on
Friday almost a 2% drop 1.67% drop the
crypto Market didn't care it was very
strong okay and also for the next two
days then you know you could say okay I
see a strength I see resilience in the
in the in the in the Bitcoin chart is
behaving quite toly you know
then on Monday what happens in the stock
market 0.35% drop that's nothing on
Tuesday
0.44% drop that's been more but still
nothing big and you know Bitcoin
suddenly crosses you can see Monday 5%
drop Tuesday 3% drop Wednesday 3% drop
you know and the conclusion that I come
with this is that this drop that we are
seeing here
is not correlated to the stock market as
many of many Traders are currently
thinking they think okay you know
Bitcoin is dropping because the stock
market is dropping that's not true
because if that would be the case then
you would have seen the drop starting
from Friday and also probably been
continuing over the weekend even though
there is not much liquidity on Saturdays
and Sundays but now instead you know
Friday strong Saturday Sunday very
stable
and then we we start to drop from Monday
when the stock market is hardly making
any any price difference you know to the
downside so it's quite obvious that this
drop isn't because of the S&P is
dropping and I can stop by think that
you know it's a bit odd that you know
Friday you got by big hack then crypto
show strength nothing happens then on
Monday 3 days later we see a massive
Liquidation cascad in the crypto Market
there has been already $500 million
worth of long liquidations hit in by bit
today is going to be also H more numbers
adding to to the
amount
and right after that they announced that
they're starting to repay their loans
because yes by B they took loans to
replace those funds that got hacked that
got
stolen
so it seems a bit weird I don't want to
say it I'm not
you know a conspiracy guys I don't have
a team fall hat on but um this is one of
those times that make you doubt of you
know what what is really happening
Behind These candles it just seems a bit
weird okay now if we talk about Bitcoin
from um price action and structural uh
point of view then we lost the range
lows that's really bad news now you know
we had these lows here that was um
87,000 point1 that could be support the
first time it held yesterday held today
let's see what it's happening it's
possible that today's drop that we are
seeing is to hit those
liquidations that there okay because if
you look at this there's some
liquidations right there okay there
that's at
85,00 exactly where we are right now at
Okay so it's possible that the drop we
are seeing right now in this moment it's
only a spike down to hit these
liquidations of early long positions
okay and then if we can
reclaim that support that doed white
line okay who knows what happens now
I'll tell you what I think well what I
what I'm looking for next week I do need
next week to see a recovery of the range
lows okay I need to see a recovery not
of the support but of the actual range
lows I need that by next week because if
that happens then I think okay you know
that was a sake out God knows why that
was a sake out to was the support you
know then you reclaim the range lows and
back to normality we can continue Trad
in this range okay however if we don't
see that next week and instead we see
something like this you
know I don't even care you is something
Bing like this that and that is telling
me we are going to continue dropping low
and that Target I have it quite clear
guys it's
77,000 why here you can see that 77,000
is in a very random zone lower you have
a very strong support which would be 71
72,000 that would hold that support but
7 77,000 guys is two very important
levels first of all is the CME Gap that
you can see here that again most C gaps
I think it's
88% of them they get filled at some
point now the problem with the c Gap is
the same as the long weeks they get
filled but you don't know when well
although long weeks are stronger than CM
gaps but the question here is that if
you don't
recover the range lows which are this
ones here okay and in fact you can see
here a very
a small CME Gap there okay so if we
don't Target the CME Gap to the upside
first so that would need you know give
me a recovery of the range lows and then
you know can continue trading like this
okay so if we don't get that then we're
going to go straight away towards the
CME Gap right so in the next week we
recover the range lows or I would say
that it's highly likely that the the the
the following weeks will drop towards
77k CM gap which is also by the way
guys the weekly 50 ma in Bitcoin okay
cuz you can see here you do like this
weekly time frame you see there guys
it's at 67 to 5K right now it's going of
course continue creeping upwards
eventually reaching 77k but then you
have two confluences to the idea that
77k it's a level that should hold also
the weekly 50ma is historically the best
indicator in Bitcoin to analyze whether
if we're in a bull or a bare market so
it's possible you know that we drop
towards 77k retest the weekly 50 ma feel
the CME Gap to the downside that
imbalance is done and then prices can
continue going higher and resume the
trend and wouldn't look anything like
anything bad in a in a higher time frame
if you saw something like this you know
it doesn't look that bad really so and
again to avoid this from happening we
need to recover the range lows next week
which is true that it looks quite hard
and quite difficult that it happens so
pay attention to that guys uh that's
what I would like
to to tell you okay uh keep an eye on
let me go back for our time frame keep
an eye on on
91,500 Range
lows and if I remove all these drawings
here that I've done I'll tell you what
I'm looking okay
if
if this drop here that we are seeing
right now if that is basically The Hunt
of these liquidations here okay there a
fast recovery over Wednesday and
Thursday very aggressively get back
above the dot line that's where you can
open a long position and Target the
range lows okay and this move here can
happen very quickly in one or two days
it can happen on you know Wednesday
Thursday or Thursday Friday it wouldn't
be something crazy but it's true that is
difficult to happen and my main point in
this video is that you know if we don't
Rec over the range lows by next week
including next week okay so you have the
deadline of next week if we don't
recover the range lows that's
91.5k next week if we don't do this you
know then it's likely that we drop
further to 77k okay so if we see
something like this next week then it's
very possible that the next that the
following weeks we continue dropping
there so be very careful with that guys
I'll continue keeping you updated but
these are right now my high time frame
thoughts and Views in this precise
moment so that's what I want to say guys
thank you so much for watching I don't
want to take more more of your time and
I'll see you soon